To do real tracking,
we have to specify these things.
In particular, we've got state and state
dynamics and we've got a sensor model.
So in the math, it's easy.
We just write x and
we say, x is the state.
But the state of what?
Montana, what, Missouri, you know, what?
No.
Is state of the object.
Everybody says, oh,
it's state of the object?
Well, what does that mean?
It's obviously some
representation of the object.
Its position, its velocity.
Maybe something about whether it's happy
or sad and that sounds like a joke.
But actually, if you can think about
tracking the state of the object,
there's no requirement that the state
be a purely physical thing.
It's anything that can have an influence
on a sensor measurement that you want
to know.
Speaking of sensor measurements or
speaking of z.
That's the measurement, but
the measurement of what?
What measurement are you
going to use and
how does the measurement
relate to the state?
So, if we're going to do real tracking
we have to know these things.
And finally,
where do you get your dynamics from?
Do you go to the, the, the, the dynamics
shelf at Home Depot and say, I,
l need some dynamics please?
You know, where are you going to
get these for computer vision?
The discussion we're going to use
today comes a bit from this paper and,
and the idea of using particles and
sample based representations
of densities, that wasn't new.
That was known in a variety
of mathematics and, and
other engineering fields.
But this is this is the paper that
really brought it to computer vision.